welcome back to 8701
so in this section we look at electro
weak unification
so the aim is to combine the weak and
the electromagnetic interactions the
issues we can see here are
first the strength of the interactions
are very different
this can be mitigated by the fact that
we have heavy gauge bosons involved
and we have seen our heavy particles as
being used as mediators kind of
change the strength of the interaction
so this might not be a big issue
the second problem is that the structure
of the coupling is very different you
have seen for qed
that there is a vector coupling and for
the weak interaction that there is a
vector axial coupling
this one minus gamma 5 with vector minus
axial coupling
so one way to to
mitigate this problem is to simply
absorb
this one minus gamma 5 term in the
definition of the particle spinous
and i have to warn you this is a little
misleading and i think that led
also to some of the confusion we had in
the class before
so what we are doing here simply is we
take our spinner
and we project out with the one minus
gamma 5 term
what's the left-handed component of this
speed noise
this is just a projection in the
definition of this and we can do this
for anti-particles as well as for the
right-handed components
as well good so now we can look at the
currents again and we look at this weak
current
which you have seen we can write as you
know our anti-neutrino here gamma mu
times 1 minus gamma 5 half times e
now if we now define
[Music]
our particles with gamma matrices we
find that
this simplifies quite a bit because we
now find the current
which can be simply written as a vector
current so we mitigated this
quite nicely so what now happens to our
electromagnetic interaction here so we
have an electron coupling to a photon
we can project out the right-handed and
left-handed component and then we have
to add them
together again when we do this we find
that
this the component of
the left-handed component a current
corresponding to the left-handed
particle and the current corresponding
to the right-handed particle there's no
mixed term here
because of the way gamma matrices or
gamma 5 matrices multiply
so that's nice this also explains why
the ellicity is not changed in qed
you basically see this from the algebra
involved in those equations
good so far we haven't done anything we
have just
changed the notation so we can go one
step further and we
re use the concepts we introduced and we
talked about
qcd or the strong isospin and since we
can nicely describe those currency of
those particles
you can maybe see if we can uh write
a neutrino and an electron as part of a
duplet
and when we do this we rewrite the
current the positively charged in a
negatively charged current
as simply the left-handed components of
those
of us of those duplets i introduced a
new matrix here tau plus and tau minus
and they're simply combinations of tau 1
and tau
2 which are in fact the party mattresses
it's just the re-labeling as well
so there's a lot of re-labeling going on
not to confuse you
but we have simply written this current
this positively charged weak
current and negatively charged current
um
where we rotate a neutrino into an
electron or an electron into a neutrino
using the weak interaction great
so now we can write this current here
as a third component of this current and
we see when we write down the third
component of this current using
tau three here we find that something
looks
something which looks like a neutral
current right so this is something like
a neutral current
where we have a neutrino coupling to a
neutrino and the left-handed electron
coupling to the left-handed electron
a vertex vector where there's an
interaction with what's going on
this is not quite the full story yet
let me remind you about the definition
we used also in isospin which is
the gilman shima
equation which connected the electric
charge to the isospin
in the strangeness of the particle and
we do the very same thing we have an
isospin
component and a so-called hypercharged
component
that's similar to the strangeness we had
before
and q is the electric charge of the
particle involved
and so with this we can now define an
isis hyperspin
current which is given as two times the
electromagnetic
current minus two times the third
component
of the um the third component
of the v current here and so now we find
interesting effects here so there's a
new component which also couples the
right-handed particles
so the missing part here some of might
have seen this already
that this neutral current in the upper
equation didn't
didn't connect or didn't have a
contribution from right-handed particles
and since there's right-handed electron
which coupled to
z both on there needed to be this kind
of additional trap so now we have a
current which includes
the right-handed particles as well so
that's great
we can generalize this by writing those
duplets for all particles we know
there's an additional kind of caveat
here we haven't talked about this too
much
we have to consider the fact that mass
eigenstates are not really
the same eigenstates which participate
in the weak interaction
right now we can ignore this we later
come back to this question
and then we can write the three
components of our
isospin current and our hypercharge
current as well
note that this em current here is our
electromagnetic current
good so now we we wrote this and we find
some somehow
very close a consistent picture we find
that there is a charged current and then
there is a neutral current
in the weak interaction but what we
actually wanted to do
is combine the weak interaction and
electromagnetic interactions now let's
look at this again
and start over again so we have a an
isospin current here
which couples to the three component the
triplet the isospin triplet
so this is a w1 2 w3
triplet and then we have the singlet
here which couples
to the hypercharge very good
so now if i try to identify now
components which we already know the
first thing we can do we have to make
sure that
we find our our w plus
and w minus both ends again and they're
simple
linear combinations of the w ones and
the w twos
and then the next thing i have to do is
i have to find my electromagnetic
interaction
and we can do that by finding
this a this is a photon as a linear
combination of the third component of
our triplet
isospin triplet and our singlet and what
you see here is that
there is actually mixing going on so we
basically rotate those
with this mixing angle which we already
introduced sine
sine omega the weak mixing angle theta
theta omega c sorry theta w
so we find that the photon can be made
out of the mixing of the
third component of the isospin
triplet and the singlet component
b mu and similarly we can find the z
boson as the other component in this
mixing the other state we find in this
mixer
the way we find those mixings here is
through the couplings we already know so
we find this
omega g times sine theta
w is equal to g prime
cosine omega w and that's equal to the
electromagnetic coupling and then
similarly we find a solution for
gz so what we have seen now is that
apparently we are able to combine um
the weak and the electromagnetic
interaction by mixing
and by introducing the weak isospin and
by mixing
isospin triplet components with a
singlet component
and so we find a picture which is
consistent with the w plus for w minus
photon and the z builder so that's very
nice